OF OURT PASGR PRONYSAM AMETIT A
I'ONM TYRK CLARO FMARHE T CRTE
ENESPRIDIBALTI L
RYRA.
WER''YEA RLL TLA GDTHA YOU CLDOU
UJOINGHTOS NI
IDN FT,AC I TNKH' IT'S I'T'
RED. GLYOO
I HPEAPN TO BE AYOH JNNH CASAN F
A'O  SI'EAM RNTYLL IDESERTEN I
UTISTH BT' 'SLS AO AIAROPPPR
TE
RHE TRAR CTEIB LRYRASEEC BAU
PRENTARTED URSEO TOK JE
EATTH H WAS ANOU CSIF OUN JE
CAERRTAS CHHHO TUGHA TTRO P
Y
YMAOT N BE TUTE,RU BT' 'ST' 'S
INGOGO T BE A REAYLLESNT IERNGTI
EVINENG G TOETHE TICOL PITAL
SIDEF OYOH JNNAS CH ASOU YL''
ABPROBR HLYEAHTON TIGDERE PSI
T
ERCARTNEAS W O OF INK THI A
COLEF ODERE PSIIANTL
CAESIDNDAT JHA TTNNOHYAS CH SDAI
AT HEE HUP S MRTPOED
HAIL
ARSTEWY FOT LEIS AHOUTR TIGONHT
AEMICHGRL EW UP IN NEWNDNG ELA
ICAPILMESHRI-A FCARIN
ILY
LYFAMIED MOVD RO AUNA LOTHE WN
WAS A S KID TIXESIMEEF BORE H
SWAEV SENRS YEA BLD O,RE TUTHE
REWE AEOU CPL OFSHI TNGHA TT
REEA RNSY LLCO ITEISNT
HIS
LYFAMI
EYTH WEERLL REAYIT POLALICM FRO
EE THTH STAT.PONDIN
THEYLD WOUOV LEICOL PITS
AONTIALND LALOCIT POLS.IC
THEYE WEROC DEMTSRA-U PROONNI
DLOVE FDR AND J,FK BUTIS H
FAO AERLSSETR SESD THE
IMANRTCEF O THEBI ATYLIO T
WREITS AE H PUTT I YOUDEE NDE T
A
VE ANDOM CMA O TFHENG ESHLI
LAGEUA INRD O TOCE SUCED A
N
HA MDICELNEOM CBID AFLL O
TH
EOSHI TS.NG
'I' ASRE GAT BUNKGACRODOR FHE T
TIPOLILCAIF LEND A OIM TESAS T
FJO
ASNYHN C
INIT ADDNIOHIO T TSOO BKHA MIC
L
ITS HAWR EN TEORSETEDID NVE
BOHEOTR S.OK
CLININUDGONON CFRNGTI THE WAR
INCHER ORO FNTEOR FAG
TIPOLI.
HE IS ARIIS HTOAN OFAROP PUL
URCULT AEND ARIIS HTOLCAIS ADV
O
IL FMS AND THO SWSIK LE MAD
MEN, AN' HE'SLS A ASSRO PFEOR
RI AOFMEIVNCA CIOIZILAT ANT HIS
MEHO INNC FRA
SOALOI JNGS UON THTIG AS
IASTHIORN ANDIAEO GRGTA STE
ERUNIVROTYSI P.SSFEOR
JOLACM MILN JN,OHHES I T
AU OORF ABE NUMRF OOO BKS
UDINCLMEGIN A ECARINCSDEPIMI
RE FINRTGEM ROTHRO FNTES LIN
OF THEPI ODOISI CRIS SKIMONG
TY
ERWRPEIT TSHE 60SGRND UER
,
ESPRS AND REISF O ATIERLTNAVE
DIMEAESEA BTLND A STOSNEND A HE
ISHE T CDEFOO-UNR OUR
INOU-FND EGTODIRHE RATFR OHE T
S60 THERN JOUALF ORYIS HTO
CSLIPOTIULND A C
RETU.
'WE'REOINGO T HEAV A
ERCONV BTISAONWEETEN THE TWOF O
TH,LLUT B A OFS UN IHE T
ENAUDIILCE WLET G AHA C TENC
OAS
ST QKUENSIO AT TTO BHEOTOFM
REE THSC.EN
LELITTLA PCE FOROU YAN C TEYPN I
YO QUEIOSTNND A IL''E B
RINIMOTOT TNGHAE'ETLL GO T
IOSTHENT JUS A LTLITE. BIT
SO ' IOWT'SIME S TOITK BAC
D
ARLENBO AUTNN JOHYAS CHND A SO
MANTGELEAEMIN CH JANL D'NOH I
'L
RN I TOVT ER
YOO U.
ANTH YK.OU
KSTHANOR F THEAT GRE
UCTRINOD
ONTI.
AYES,ELOLBSUT
D W IL,EL I IHI TNKV''ON DE
O
FLEUP OSVE ENT WELHIT HPM FRO
CTHE CTEARRTEENR APE ANDCAALL
AOKBOSND I'T'T JUS AAT GRE
PL
RESU.
KTHANOU VY MORHUC FNGOS HTI
O
OTHF
US.
ISI WH WOUE CLD BOGE TINHEETR
PEUT,ON BHI TSL WIL TAV HEO D
EAEON RNSOAN I W TTO A BE IND
O
IKDUL L B TEOE ISO PNERHIN T
S
CAUSE MEIK IND ARE ALL REA
YGO
EN FODRI.DS
L'I'US JT T SAYTHARO FMHE T
O' WETE'VENO KWN ETHHAC OER
FO 2BO AUT Y0NDRSEA AT'S
N
ALL REA RYNGAREWDIONND A W
L
NDFRIE
IPSH.
RIDUNGHA TIO PTER ADNDT I
EDCUOCRRO T MEUSTEC RTLENY
ATTHVE OR20HA TT  PEA-YRIOERD
THT
AVEER HN BEEE MYAN TES
I'RD HVEEA YAL TKUT ABOHI TS
WHOKBO, HIC ISGOM CINUT OOW N
.OUTHGH
TH'E' AON LGTA GES PONTIIOERD
S
ON TYMEUS JT DIONTN'OU Y'VE
NEDO AFOT L OTHERS HI TNG
INH
HEINE  T.NT IRO
IIK LE THEN I IHE TCTRONTDUN.IO
UYO TDOL ATO SRYBO AUTHE T THE
FI O ATNDYIM TEHA TTOU Y
WEO TH- H AIGDENONUC ATIND A
IT AASN A.TIUCON
TH WASEL SOHNGLI JYNN CH
ME
BIMOLICH WA,HIOU Y
LEKNACOWOUEDG YLD COUOT N HEAV
FORD Y HADN A ITIERNTES
N
FY EDDIXPGIN EEIEERNC.HE TRE
IDEREIFOUOU Y WT JLDUS
STHABYT  SHANGRI TT
UR S.
KSTHAN
EAN THISSPE SAK E TCTXALYO
THEOI P.NT
USUYO JE MTAD YHA TT'O'VEEA HRD
MENGAL TKI JBO AUTNNOHYAS CHOR F
RS Y20EASEEC BAUHI TSAS W
IN
R2004FTHTIG A.ER
SHCAN I CUN JETEARR HAD
OT H
EDPASSWA AY ANDHE T ESTEATAS W
NICTAUIONG OFF ALLF OHE T
IRAF
THIRFAS  SOTBY'A'S D I H
I
HADEENNGOR WKI ONS THITH O
T TOKHAY TON MEDTIENON
BT
THE ETNA
WAM R.
ANDN I S00 22NDYON ABIOL CUM
A
HADOM CE OUT WHITHI T CSCEONRT
RE
GRDCOINHA TT HAD NEEEREV B
BASLEED IOREFET WAS
RO FM
MBDECE OERF9. 196
TH WEASOR RECDDE M AT
ISN
SQREUANAR GDEND AT AHI WCH
HNNYSTAS CH TSARINPE SAKG
AITQUE. LOT
INAC FT AUTBOHE TIETN WAR S
H
ADAT HLL REAUE PYIQ MDY
FAN AND 'ID DN'TNO KWHA TTE H
EV
ENAD HAI SDINNY ATHBOG AUTHE
VIARMNA WNT UIL IEA HRDHA TT
REINRDG SON WHEHE TUC A
ONI
TWASINAKGLA PCE D IIDECED
TO
JUST GO CCKHE IT O.UT
EATNO RURYLL SEHA WT I
OU D
N LEARD I WASUT ABOO TIV GE
P
INAC FT B IAUECSEUG THOHTHI T
S
INIS K ODF PSSNTOILE LEI' IT'S
ST P ONESOERNER AFTERNO ATH
BIN,GIN ONOOU Y K AW, PRAIF O
I
SBO COWYOOTS SR ONGETOMHI
ANDHI TSEOU CPL IAM CE ANND SAT
O
NEXO TKI ME NDF O E.ITXCED
THEDI BIDNG HAD AEALRDY SVRRED
D
THAND NWOE MAT AOM SENT POI
AS W MDE TTHA IUGHOHT I WAS
GO
O GIN TD F AND YOUW KNO
LIOU Y SDAI WR  POOANSIASST
R
RESOFSOET  ATH
IM TE.
ASIT WTT PREYH MUCNGOT NHI I
CO
FFDUL AD.OR
HE ISO SYISEPHLAI S WDL,E' I'
M
JUSTERE AS AIS H,RITOANOU Y
PIQUR YEDOUESNT IER S ATND
HE
DASKE ME YOUNO K WW,HYT WHA
IASTHIOR I BNETEERNTES
IDN
NYJOHN AAS CHND I SDAIOM S
G
TABOUIEHE T VARAMTN WND S
F NDKI O OT CUME.FF
ANDAI SD,L WELDYNY ABO WHO KNO
HIANYTUT ANGBOYOH JNN CHAS KWSNO
HE WAS RCAUBEPLIHT RNIG
AI SD WL,EL I D'O'W KTNOBO AUT
.THAT
INKHI PPLEIG MHT
AV HE
ERDIFFDETEN IASUT ABOIS H
PO BCATILUNKGACRODND A I
FOTQUEDHEMRO TAN M INLA B
,CK
KYOUUTW,NO B W BRIEANGCKLA FOR
THOO PRNDHE TNEA BTEN DOW A
N
DHE SD, SAIH, OEL WL,EA Y
H
,SUREHAUT B T'T'SEEC BAUE  HSWA
A
TIHR CISOU,AN YNO KW,E HAR CED
TABOUEEO PPLUSBV OIO Y ALYND
ON
O,OW SE WAV HEHI TSIN KDF
LIDLRI FENTEDEY BAT ND A IIT
Y OITNL OIN KD AFDIRFFME
HIS
IDEA M INYEA H TTHA I SULHOD
INEIGSTAT FHI TS BTHURER
E
I HADD REA OERTHH CAS
BIS.PHRAIE
ID REAIS H OWNOB AUTHYGRIOAPND A
NODY HADR EVEYEA RLLRA GLEPPD
WIHE TIT POLF SIC O CHNJONYHAS
AINAY WHA TT IHO THTUG
AS W
PARTULARIS SLYAT SINFYG AOND
IT
AS WER INT BTIESNGAUECSEOU Y
KNRE T,HES I THISHI TNGHE WRE
PE WLEHOEL SFES DIBCRED
HIFELS ARIT EHELIEP RUBRNSCA O
DESCRMOATR O LERAL OR
COVEVAERTIY TS,HELL A OIN KDF
ANDO S I WER IASNTTEESDWH IN
T WATASOO Y YOUOUES DIBCREN
IH
THEOO BKE SOMNAAS FCIARNGTI ELY
EXRIENSCEHA TTNN JOHASY CHAD H
THASHE T CLUAAN FSHT MIG NOT
BEREWAF O HERE GWP UN
DOEMTRENEPUS DONVARITI DINURG
REETH GAT DIOREEPSS INS OER
HEBROTWHR O HE AOV LED LOTIE DD
AN A FAKISNDH AOMRU GESNDE A
EZABIRRENCC AID ATNDHE TN DING
WO T WDARNDWO ART SHOER ALYFT
H
E. WAR
HEOD AAS CERREEBAK FOR T
TAEDIT SILSTE M
ARITY.EUN
WEDLA PYELL R AEARTIMY POTAN
LERO.
ANAS I W CUS JT,IOURUSOU Y
,KNOWHI WCHF OHE FVEMAORTI
EXSENRICEOHN I JSHY NNCA''
LI
YOUNK THIIG MHT HAVEYE PLAD
TH
GE BEIGST REOL IN SPIHANGIS H
HI PS ITOLICS D ANHISHI
RYTIARST
IEA MN,T' 'SAR HDO T SAYHI W
CT
EF OLL AFHO TSEAS WHE T
IOU WLDRO P LBLBAYOWNEA TDSAR
SAT TNGHAT IAS WNGRO GWIP UN I
VEPOYRTND AND AIT WSS TO RLEA
RTPOVE D AYNDTIRIEPVAUN AONRO
DI
K YM,OUISW,NO HY AM FILSWA
ORCHMU MUNFOE RTHAEAT TN A LOT
OFTH OERMP IHEEROVISDAM FIEILS
IN
EAOR NTH,STSARK AANATS HE
SURR BNDOUEDY,OU Y KWNON A
ENUSMOUL POP OIOATNFDL LAN
S
ERFARMSRE SHARSOPCRPEHO WER WE
REESLYAL D HTUTITEM EISXA H
TLYMI AEA LST HADHE TITEN BEFISA
OFNG BEI HPEELDY BHE T RLTSEOOVE
ADTISTNIRA B TONO REEDETESTL
IN NEWOMMUTYRE WHEHE TY
WE
RENE LOAD,NOOU Y KW, THE
RE
SURSOCE G TOETMS THEVEELS
K
HEON TT. FIREE
SO A KDINF O CTIBIOMNAONF O
THHIE TSNGS  I
ALRELY
RTIMPOT, BAR PT OFHA TT TOO
ISAR WMETIER EXP TNCIEETHA
YOIBES DCREHE WRE HE HIS
BR
DHEOTRD.IE
TTNO A WAR BUT DINURG THE
ARW
NGMAKIRA EXT FON MEY
TORHE
LYFAMI.TI SLL
CABEE OFHE TIRND EINURG
PORIY RTDUNGHE T W AARND
N
HE YOUNO K HW,EER SSVEHEN I T
MIIKRYTA L YEOUAY S IN ETH
CORLEAY . WLDAR
ANDAS HOU YNO KW AKI WORNG M'A'
I
ONDFANET VERSIEXP EEROUE,NC Y
KNOWAU BEC HSEEAS WALAS BICLY
SJOINIRHE T AORCE AS SNOOS A
THNOR KEAAR WAK BRE OSUT
HUSCAENO HADE TEOU WE HLDAV
ENBE DFTRAEDUROR F S
D SO IHI TNKE H HAS AEA RL
EMTHPAYND A SYPAYMTHOR FEO PEPL
INOWH F THEELVESN ISE THE
S KINDCU COFIRESTAMSNC WCHHIRE A
NOLL REAY OFIR THE OWN COSIN
H
REHIC AOLON CTRHEDLE T FCEORS
OF WCHHIRE AONTRLED
BYOT
YORSHE, .KNU OW
THBOY M MYHEOTRND A MY
OTANGRDMERRHE WNN JEOHYAS CH
CHNJONYHASAN FSO TOM SERE DEG
IAS WNGEL TLIOU Y TTHAHE T
R
TDAYTHA INK THI IAV HEER VY
EAYLD CHI MODHOSOREMIEF O
WAOMNGHI SNN JEOHYAS CH
SPITLSIA W F OHUR AILAMY AT
IMEON THEE TREAS W AYOH JNN
H
GRAUTONHAP IUR OOUSE WHI
S
NGSTRA
MYNO KW YAM FILEC BESEAU W
DO' COLLEOR MCTEM AILABIA
NDH
'E' R NREOTLLEAYTH NEIYER M
PAERSNT W DEEY TN I PHEOP
MU ACND IOV LENN JOHASY C
D
EYTHOU WLD WHACHAT THOT SNDW A
AN
T YDETE SHEAMIM TEY THE WEER
NOICOL PIT ANDN I
ANY
ENCONV SONTIALERSEEN C
INTA.
'THAT 'SHE MYOTRND A M
HEDMANOTLD WROU BOT VE TUTTHA
BEULWOD  IBO AUT
TBU YOU SGEUGSTT THAT THA SWHO
MEMESOTISOU WLDAR CRYVE SUB
E
AGMESST TESHAHATIG MHTAV HE
ST
SOL ILRE WTENADEOHIT PNEPL I
WA
T TYSHABE MAY ENVE TY DN'I'
H
N' DEYIDU'T ODRSDETOHATRE
OSOME W TFHEHASAY TTHE TW SHO
COE  HDAVEN SVERS
ELIY
ANI MERSUB SVEE.IV
I'MOT N SEUR ILD WOUSE UHE T
TERSUB SVEEIVIK LE I GETHE T
IM FSIESONALMRO TONGKI T L
F
EO PEPLHO WAT WCHHA TTHO SW
UDINCLOMGIN SEYF O M OERLD
SIHAGSIN T FTHT EYKET ELLI
ETHUB SERSVEIVHI TNGAS W TTHAE H
CARADI AL,ISRTTS YOUW KNO TO
ORPERFNG AMLOINDESI KD OF
STMAINOUAMRE CUSRYNT MIC,TA SRS
U
ON IT D'' T INKHI INAYHE T W
TH
AS CH.
GAENDGEIT WHHE TLI PUB ACNDT WHA
DEMAIM HOP PARULBLRO PBAH WYIT
YO
ND GURRA ATHMOER MNDHEOTRHO W
'DIDNTHI TNK OFELHE TMS
S S
ICPART PARULLYALITOLIC
SWAHA TT HE W OASN THIEL TL
E H
A
TDSHIEV TEL SIOISNWHOHA TT
ARAPPEEDVE ERYGL SINK WEEE
PRY CATILLWEEREVY .EK
EIHE WEDN IN ONERAY W O
HEANOTONR E SOM OFHEOS M
T
SIPRESUE INGSSST TH' WE'
RE
NGFACIOUHE T CNDRYNT ADE  HDIT
IN
AY W.
THAT WAS KDIN OFER V ODN PEAN
NO-HEA HVYDEAND,OU Y KW,NO NOT
LIHI TS ISIHA WT VEEL BIEND
ITHISS YHA WTOUUL SHONK TDHI
.'
'M K YOTOUW,NO W HERY TGIN
ORTO FE SCEOM IICOLDEOGE LALIN
ONOU AND HE CCREAM ASOSS A A
YGU WHO WASIN TRYGO T MEAKSE SEN
OFYEA RLLPL COM PATICEDALITOLIC
STRCCIUM ICEANS WTHN ET TAYHA A
O
OTFIS HRSIE VWEER WEIG RHT
DAN IHI TT TNKHAEA RYLL
RETENAD ANDO S IT'OE DSNC'T
FOFOR F YOU KNWNO OIR FSTLA GENC
OUUYO C WCHATOM SEF OHE TSE
ODEPIS AESND WHI TNK YL,ELOU
KN IS'T TTHAIC NEHA TT H'E'
INTALKTABG OUOU YEONG PE.PL
OWU YOKNARWH, O ELE A,RT YOU
KNIOUE QSTHENGNI T WDOMF
EITHRLD ESER OEMAR YBOT NAY MBE
KYOUT'W,NO 'S NEHA TTE' 'S
SA
NGYIHIOM SETNGOS PIVITEBOUT
ERVSEICREN M OBO ASO PUTRIRSNE
ET SOROM YNGHI,W, KOUNOND A HE
DHAHE TSE VIOARUSAY WSN O THE
TESIVIONW SHOF ORO INT
CG
DISCSIONBO AUTHE TSESS ISUE
THE WERTAMP IOR TNTO
IM H.
BUTIK LAY IE S N IOTN AAY W
WHEE H WAS KDIN OCI FORNG
T
ADOWN'BONYDY 'S YOAHRT,W, KOUNO
SON' DIDF'T E LELIK HE WASUT O
WA
NGVI AOL PICITALPA CAMNIG
, NNBAERASOR W Y IT,OU
NO KW
HIMARCNGT A THE FNTRO OF A
RCMAH.
ITAS WUS JTE LIKE H WAS A
ZETINND AE H WASOI DNG HHA WT
IS TTHAHE TY SULHODSI CONRDECHHI
ESTHES SS IUETFOUTHGH YLYUL,
ON
AOWNDEI W TGHMHEOR F
TH
ESSEEMLV
T SDOTHA INK THI TT'H'
TELESIVIONW SHORE ARM ENOHARE
SY
RTIMPOMPTAN I TTAORNTOHE T
RSUNDEGNDTAINIMS  AALI PUB
N,TICIZEOU YNO KWIT WUTHOHA TT
PL
RMFO.
TH'E'TH OER'HE TR'STH OERAY W
E
ESNG EAGICOL PITUE IALSS
S.
W STVHOHOOR F T K YSEOUWNO F
T69O97 1S 1 IIME THPRYAR
RMATPLFO
THEHE TOP TIC OF JYNNAS CHND A
RAAT RELNSIO IS APL COMATICED
ON
PP ACIREAT TEDHESU CEN
VIY
WITHCH WHIOU YSSDD ARET.ED I
WEIO OBVLYUS CNOANTL CALYOH JNN
A
TIL CHEIVSIG RHTER HO AND
HEIN TOO BKHA T IT W NASOTRE AWA
OF
'' DNTFEIFREOT R EKUSSOPIDE
H
EN B HE VAVEHEDHAYER SY.FUMELL
ION D''NO KWF I Y YOU CEDARO T
SSCDIUS I BT,UT YLSOU AO
SCRID H S AIMS WEOOMNE
S
ABLE TOOPEV DEL A CYACAPIT FOR
FO
NS TRRAG NDCEINOROMVE ORCGIN
SO OF THEIS RACM IHIN S M
.
DHOW W YOOUT COU Y
SAY
T ABOUHAATTH TFRAUT TOC?PI
,WELL' 'D SAYOT LE' 'HS U
BE
USCAE IT IS A CATPLOMIC
EDST
IGY,OR RHTE HRO GWSP U I
ASRTNOHERNTESARK AANSN IHE T
'THA'SELNT EIR WY
TEHI.
'THA'S DIBER SELATYTEREEGGA
.
IEA MNST EEDLIABSH B A
GO AMERNNT TNCGEYXPTHA E
Y
WSAIDR'E'OT N GNGO TO G
AGOCTNS LMS NALORIG RHT MH
ASE W LIG MHT TEIKSOO E' 'REOT N
GOG TO TRY TO ESHABSTLI LEIK
ANEG INTTERADAR FMMU COMTYNI
RREHE,NDHTIG AT' 'AR CSLE TTHA
HE GPWSRO UMO ANG R.ISACTS
TH AEREEEO PPLNIS HIL FAMY
TR
EEREHO W AAC R
TSIS.
EMAYBNCN A U WLEHO M HAYEEEAV B
N
EM MRBE OF THEN. CLA
HEER CINTALYAS HON CTEDEFERA
CEST, R
HTIG?
TANDT'H'SN ATAMP IOR PNTTAR OF
ENS HIIDNDTYTI AHE TNE KN
OWE
OFUSCAE  IS TTHAE WER
BLISDHE BY HIS FSTIRE WIF IN
HE
OI MREMRT THAE HAD HHE TSE
PALYULICAREPGL UY ODISEST THA
O
RRREU FEED TO WNH' HE'D GET
K UNINNYER GMAHE WN HE WAS IN
RE THAI FNDCEOR AOT IO
E.THES
RCALTE IIOATNSTSN DOE''EE SM
LIHE TYVE EROT GCAHY PSILUT B
ALRCATITNSIO WHCK BLA
EMRVSEICND,EN AHE TNE H RSOUECNT
THEAC BKO T HER I
ARICRTULTE GLYROANUESQ L
,
RACIOS,ST ST' 'AFS S S TEOAY
BATY THE YIM TENOOU KWS A ATH
GYOUN
AN M.
'HE' HS'E' AIS RACT HEAS H'N'
SHENLFIM HSEOO LSEIT WH TSE
STRACIUDTT AITGH, ESRI BTUT TNHE
THFEA W APGSIN HN.PE
IN TRS YHEEAER AFT GE HSET OUT
OF AHEIRCE FORNE O T ISTHA HE
SMOVE MO TPHEMIS RHTIG TSHIOWN
'THAT 'SYORAJIT PLA BCKIOULOPAT
D ANHE CANPE SNDOU YNOW
E
IDAYS AN WAY TETHA HER NEV HAD
HINISIF LEEF BEOROU ENCGERNTIN
NO BUT BCKLAPL PEOE
GUDCLINOO PR BCKLAPL PEO WEHO
E
S A SNESALMAAS WNT MEA TOE B
SEGINSHI TNG TO A WNDHO HE
TOEE S AIN KDF ODHA SRE SSRTST
EX
RIEN INIR THE PEROVTY
D
IVDEPRIOATNHA TT HEAT REL
O
OWHIS INUPN BR
NGGI.
BUT O THEERTHHI TS RLLEAY
KIND OF ODESBSSE WHEHIT TCES
DELECORNGDIST THA YOU KW,NOSEFI
L
AN LAXOM ANDER OTH DSIDND A
ICPART TARULLYNESHI OOR RECD
THATE CAM OUTN I 1AL995 CDLE
BL
SUE ANDHE TSI MIS NIPSSPI
,
HWHICS I ONE T OFHE MTOS
IVPLEXOSE I TNKHIT MOSSIXP ELO
GSRDCOINVE ER TOE COM OUTN O
A
INON VYLN I THETE UNI SDTETAS
DE SBIRINGTIREEGGAM  FONROETH
CTRSPEPE TE IVOFSEHE THE BESLU
S TIARSTE O WHARSORE SCA ODF
RTHISCOORECD UTNGMI OND AHE T
A
FLIMIESINACGIAET RALON TTHA
THEYIS INS TTTHAUD PSEYMONSE B
RIGH I ATND'T'HAT A TT P
NT.
YOU CAN ST TEEHAH CAS I HNIS OWN
WO.RK
SHERTTASO T RORECD SEOM OF THE
TOEV DOPELHI TSSE SEN OFIN KD OF
OW LAX MEINEN SSELFIM HSE A
MEMMCOIT TNTO SIAOCL RLIEASM
D
TOENOC DUMNGTYEA RLI
HA WT ICR DESNEDIB IHE TOO BK
S
OT NEA RYLLIM HN IAY S962
RUOGIN T THERO FNTF O AIL CIV
MGHRITSCH B INSADTETI PUT
OUT ADEC RORDAL CLELO BODAT SWEG
AND TRSHI WCHE WLYSU UAL TNKHI
AOFSIK LE AINDOLF O FOR RKEC
I
TH AUN B OCHFK WOR OON SGSN
IT
NTBU IT FACOS MTF O THE WKOR
NGSOSRE ABOUTLO EXPEDITLA BCK
ME BEINGRO TERZERIDHT RIG
TSBJSUECO TFIOR HRILE VCIOE
LY RNGHIS,NDHTIG AOM SEF O
ESTHE S
GSON.
HE FEASTIR H ORDNLU BESND A
T
ISMISSNIPPSII T.GH
O DAN SK THI IN'I' KTHS AT
F
METAN TOENOC DUMNGTI THE S
L
ITREALCH WYHIE H HN SADEE A
D
HI
''N SEE IHI TSNUSAR VIO WS.AY
'HE'D SNEEIN CHAGS GAN
ME SEEECSHD ARS PPROERUSED
GHRIT?
THAT YOU KW,NO HE UESERNDGO A
RE
LYALOR IMP KNTTADIN OF
SFTRANONMAORTISCR AOST THA
PEOD OF THE 5 6 A0SND.0S
YSO B T TEIM HEAS H T
ONVILESI HHO SW'E'OU YNO KW,E
PR
TYETH MUCN AUSBV OIO AEOCDVAT
FO ECIRAALYALQUITN I A WAY
EATTH HSE PREACSNT RHEONE  T
TE SSIVIONW.HO
SO NEREVAS WE HVE ERAL CDLE TO
T COACUNOSR FOTHTE LEET.
WHID DCOHE TY  A OMEUT HNDE
AVEREV HESWO  TANORER F
IM .
HEEV NERECID D B TSEAUYHE TYHE
CA OUTER AFT HEIE DD TTHA TTHA
OKHA TTIV VN.IA
CUMH'A'SIR FSTIF W PEUTUT O
OCAME.UT
IN FTACFTERHE HAD P
SEAD
AJUSTERFTHE SAS PDSE IWA AY
N20
.08
Y TSOHE YOUNOW, IHI TNK
AH
YFANSOU RD,EA YOU KWNO
HIEREVYTN'HA TT' ESRVE COMUT O
TABOUAS CHOU WLD BEWA ARE OF
LEOSTHE  BERTTS,Y  TUTH'VEHAN'T
I 'N' AHI TNK'BONYDY 'S
LY
TDEAL TIT WHMHE ANDHE TST QUENIO
OF IAC REICPAN RTETARUL DLAI
NOTIUNL
'IT'SER INT TTIESNGOHI TNKBO AUT
E
USCAEIMOM SETESHE WNEEO PPL
DARE TNKRUYHEAY SNG THISHA TT
TH
THE REAEVLOM SHIETNGHA T
A
HEEYB TV'Y'RE REPEDSSHA '
SNOTYIAOCLLTACC AEPTE BLBU
LEOP, SAY YOU KHIWNO TSNG TTHA
'ERTHE'S SAKPE N OUTESEONNSND A
IVUYO GM  TEHES PAASF I L YOUKOO
B TATHE OANALCEF L HIS IE,IF
TH
OUKIN YO D GDOO J OOBF
TITREAT TNGHASS IUEH WIT WH
IVNSSEITY.IT
AHYE.
KTHAN
OU Y.
'IT'ESS BNKNT OWSLB AUMERES
ONPRISS.LB AUM
TH T AEREHES ONEHA TT IE LIK
THOS MT AND HEAR CLE HLYAD A
SPMPLIA EHYAT ORR  OITNDBO W
R
S,ONISER DUT B I'O'TNO KWF I
PE ALERE ARE OFOW H
HA T
LODEVE.PS
DE WION Y IRFOU COULDOU Y
D
USDISC.THS AT
SU
HE HNT SADPEE SOMIM TE IN JLAI
F,MSHIEL?IG RHT
HEIE DD AEW F R-IUNNSIT W THHE
WLA NEREV MPE SNTHAEOR TN A
GHNITR OWO TN IAI J AL,NDE H
VENEREN W TTO P
SORIN.
OUALTHRE TGHHE WASHI TSAS W A
LYWIDEEL HDFEL BIEVE EN AFT
FOTHE OMLSNRI PSODEC ROR CEAM
OU
TPL PEOSSE AEDUMHA TT YOUE H
WA
FO PSER AINRMGS ARI PINNESOR
H
ERI PN,SOOUNO KW,HA WD STEN
ADDR JS ESTOCANNOHY .SH,OU KWNO
TBU HE HAD NEREVONENRI PSO
TI
,ME BUTE H HADRT STA
NGORRFMIT ARI PNSSO E ASLYAR
7 1AS95END A H DID TSHID KINF O
QUSTY TLJUINEL RATAGAI
TOEN MHO WHI TNKOU YNO KW,E H
RSUNDETODTO IS AEING
SHVEPORIT  MEDOS T TOFHEEIM A
LOF OHE TMRO FMHE TOU STHIK L
E
NDAS W ANOOU Y KW,TI GET TNG
H
TOR ENDF TCK SHETIIMOM SET
N
MS TER OF TIRHE R-IUNNSH WIT
ETH
AW L.
SOGA HE VE MYANRTON CCES, YOU
ITOWKN WUCUTHO M FH AFAANRET
OONISSRVE THE Y
RSEA.PR
HE EOYNJEDYI PLA TNGTM HEBUS A
ALHE TDKEUT ABON IER INTEWVIS
TER,NOOU Y KOTITW  BHIREHED
.
TO S THEKS LOO INHE TIRYE ES
O KELI TESEHE TL, SOUOU YW KNO
OKINDFIN DRAED OUTF OHE TSE
BEMAHUN  WGSINHO AREN IHE TSE
PLSE TESHERI HOREBL P
CELS
GDOIND HAR AIM TE,NDO SAR P OTF
WHETE WAN D TDOO,IASP EECYLL
THWI TTHAST FIR ATMOL FSONRI PSO
RERDAS WLMOSLIKELA AN
LO YX,OUNO KWAS W TO DTUMOCEN
ETH SNDOUSHEF O TNS IONTUTITI
IT ALFNDHE TSOU SNDF OHE T
PRISERS TVEMSHEEL Y ASNDOUAN C
TYPRETYAS EIL WBO AUTFCHHI OHE T
RIOTW PNSOS LB AUM B TISHETES
E.ON
AND'HE TR'SCT ALLUAY AHI TRD O
H
AT YOU DN'I'TWE SN,DE BUTHE T
UENSA QNDINNT AMOL FSONE OSRE A
THSAM FOUNE OSND AO TE MHE T
IN
INRETESTNG TGHI AUT THE
FOOR ROMECHAISD  TOEHET  D'S'
T
'SNOE'EAT R PYLLYLANY A OF
SIT HSIK LE HE HERSAI TLO THEHI
E
EISTLTYIRNTELO THE T
RIEXPECE O THENERI PSO.RS
'ERTHE'SS LOT OSSOF NG
BO AT
ONPRIS
C ODF HRSOUE,'E'OT NHE T
TFIRSRYOU CNTTRT AISO T WTERI
ETHES OIN KDS SFGSONR OLAY
TH
INEES K S ODSFGSON,UT BE' '
SH
ST FEIRNE O P TOYHE TSE
SO TSO THE PRSSORINE AND
CAHEEUR TCT RIREANIO ON TE.AP
ODAN ST' ' L ASBITLITE D HTAR
R US TO GAC BKOW NAU BEC
SE
'WE' CREHASS FANNOWSE THE
RDRECOSOS EL WL, ANDY' THE
'VE
RBEENDEAELSE A MLIILON
TERFFENS WAYND AE WAVE TH
TEMPCOLE YET SS, KOUWNO IN THE
BO
T SXETTHAOU YISAN C LN TETO
OTBU TACO G BK ANDNIS LTEEO  TTH
INIGALIN V,YL YOUW KNORO FM
6819NIS LTEO THA TTEC RDORSH FRE
IS FLLEAYTICIASNANG TONK THI
AB TTOUHE OTITHF E N WMEHEOU Y
KNOU YE HAV ARE PDESINT
RIDARIX NO'HO W'SUNOR F
OF A OCEN LAW O ANDERRD
CALIRNFOIAHE WRE THERI PNSOAS W
DCALOTE IONHE T CRTCEAS W
ORPERF ADMEAL RSONDNEA RGALS A
MHUCAW L OND ANDERRD A
N
'HEREC'S D  KSHINOFNO KWIN TAK
H
E SEIDF O YOU KRDW NOHA IONT
ALIMCRIN K YS,OUW.NO
SO IHI TNKT' THA 'S RLLEAY
REINTEINGXA EFLEMP O HIS
YTHPAY,W KOUNOAYHE T WHA TT
HE
AT RELOES TEO PVEEPL EN P
WHER WE CARLELYY UI GLT
OF
LERRHOIBS,RI CMENOOU Y K
LLWET PARF OHA WTES MAK TSEHO
SCORERDO S ERAORNADIRYO TE M
IE
T' ' TSHE ITIERNTACH WONIT
ENAUDI.CE
ETH SGSONREAT GRE
RE TTHE'' AOLSHE TT SOR OF
ENAMBISE NTOIHEND A TNSES RPO
HATE GSET H TOIS S
GSON.H
WANDOULDOU YE WLINGO T
K
AB STOUFEOM OT THA OOM SEFSE THO
MIDYNACS ON R THE?ORECDS
.AH
RESU.
IEA MN,E' 'SOU YW, KNO'HE TR'S
A
E'THE'S AEW F OON SGS TNHE
CORD ITHS AT AHI TNK.RE
PRODTUCF O THEAY WHA TTHT EHE T
ERODPRUCHEND A T MAB LELAGANED
IT
LE IKWENO KW ON THEN OE SID
TOOF O THEMOL FSO RORD THAT
DIEYTH EDTEN IOM SEGS SON FMRO
STHE SONECD.
MOHEF O TDEC RORS IE MAD UP
TFROMHE SIR FSTETND AHE T KIN
F
RLLE CVET EYDIINHE TM O S
'ERTHE'S ARE THE'' A KIND OF RES
LLFAIS RNG TEHIOI GNG O WHE
RO
AVU HE LEIK R ALLEAY EGITXCIN
O
NG FDLOOLWE BY A STOF
RE
VEECFLTI YON SGOUNO KW
FO
OWLLED BANOTR EX
TICG
.SONG
BUTH, YEA' YOU 'REHTIGT  THA
HO
U TNO KW T WHEAYT HEPE SSAK
TO THENERI PSORS IN BWEETEN THE
SSONG ISS ATAMP IORNT A TSHE
THT TGSHAE' 'S S,GIINNGOU Y
SOWKN,OE HLE CLYGN ALIS
ELHIMSWIF THHE TMHE WN YOU
,
'HE'SAL TNGKIBO AUT G THE ORDUAS
E
''SKEDOR ARI DNKF OAT W,ER
NOUYO K T AW,NDY'H'W SRELOO
IINBRG TTOIM H ANDHE TRO CWD
ARTSRI JEATNG A TRIHE P
NSO
ONPERSLNE FOR NIKOT LERE TINATG
EITHRST GUETE BSET T ARNDHE
SET TEHAOU Y HE TTHE TY
AR
E,OU Y KW,NO AOSLMTTH BROSER
BE
NDHIS  BARIS VYER CYOARLE, U
KNOW PPLE ARO WTEUTBOHI TS
TIKNYO, U  IOWN I TNKHIAM CRE
ZIMAGA ONER C MCUIRSESAZAGIN
,YL
W KUNO KIN OF RKOC AND
ZIMAGA W TNEHE ITERIRSE, LIK Y
N
HE,OW WREHE WUS MT TSHI GUY
TBE A ORAY M TBESEHOLI ROL
HEEON WT MREUS GHI TS A BUYENGST
A BTOEEBL TOE EL RATSE TTOHE
PR IERONS TNHEAY WT THAE H
DOEOND A PEOEPL PADEPL HOU Y
KN SOMODY PIK LE
TEORR
NEWAGOR HADUT PUT O P A
SORN
EDTHEM RORECD Y THEREAEEF BOR
BUT IT WASLL ADEEC RORND I
HT
IOSTUDT WAALL OWU YOKN
SO
OUSO PTRIN H AN'SS DRE IEDN
YO
W, KUNO ATR SEDIPPS JUMT UION
THOV CER OF THELB AUMROR PTE
WA
SERGN IOUUT B Y D'T GET A
ENSE LIKOU YO  DTHWIH CASHA TSE
O
W, KUNOE COULD BONE EF O
,THEM KOU YWNO T ANDTHA HE
TERELASO TM THEIK LETH BROSER
REDEVIO GRDCOINNEF O O OFSE THO
WOWSHSE'REHE HG'S HANGVI WIT
HAESE W IT TE AS AIR DTYR O
EXD.RAPETE
LODSOW TAR P ANRIAR WRNDE O
AUA G,RDOU Y KEAW,NO Y
H.YE,A'Y
MOS.NT
'ERTHE' TS AETYIN DNLAI I
OUR
TBOOKROTHA P NBLBAYLSNE O EE
SSIBEDE MEIL WLSK A AUTBOOU Y
SADLA PYEIT WHOM SIMETES' '
MA
BETRIYOL,IL SE 'AS WN'ET TH
ONRMER PFO.ER
AN IDS P IT ATAR HNDED SAIHA TT
O
OMEF TFO PHEERERRMSERE
PO YIBSSLYT MOUUS TE BERU N
ECABEUS YOUTE WROT. I
LLWE,T' ' TSHETO SRYT THAER MLE
MHIMAGLEER HECRDGA RNTOUED TO
YSTOR TAN MYHAESIM T NTEW YR'E'
EEVNE OR  YEAHEATTH T TARHE WNDE
ARHAGGASD WVI CONFEDCT ORM AED
RO
YERBBY,OUW KNO AND WAS
GRVSEINE TIM AT SNT QANUEINND A
SHCAAMEN IS A THE HERDLEAIN
N
AIL BL TTHANC IDELUDER OTH
CORTYTR AHETSIS TOL C
NSLI
,KIDSOR F E,MPXALEHI WO ACHLS
SES KIK LE ODIN WEIRDNG THI
TO HEAVHE TSEIK LNA TEEERSGE
BA
YCASILLN IHI TSRI PNDNSO A
EAENTH Y M IH,NEA LEOU Y C
AI
LE MNDERRDAG HGATEC RANHA TT
YSTORN IPLUL MTIELA PS.
HEHEDAI T WREEERIP STRRSPE IN
YEANAHEMT  ISES IAS W JUST
LYLIUNKENWND A UE, B Y
I
SAID IUP TSEPORITHA PNSO
TSNCCOERRE A F BLEALN TYHE
WAE.ID
' DION 'THENKHI T'R' SSNGETOMHI
PELE DFTTOO  OMO AENNYRE OMR A
I G?ON
I LLWE, N'D'.KNT OW
QGOODN.STUEIO
DO' HKNT O' IOW'M IEE FL
E
I HRDEAF OOM SNEEO OOI DNGNE
LYCERENT B,UTAN I C''HI TF O
WHHA TTS  IINAS C HIMLF, UYO
OWKNNUON CTI TEOO DHE TM IONT
S,E TH80UT BEDTA SRTO TOS LEIS H
IATHENUSAU BSMEC A HSEESE HAI S
D
THE MRE PSSYAN.IM TES
HET FELHIIK LE OR WK OEHN BFAL
SO POFRIRMREN FO
WASN''LL REAORY W.
NGKI.
KYOUHAWNO T HTEID D'N' HE
'DIDN 'T AEENYOSITEIV EECFFT
CO
RONGMI F
IMT.
E'THER 'S 'REHE' PS ATTREY
GR
T.EA
UAN CIN FDT IN I ANI UYRSVEIT
ORO THE STETA OFIF CALNIORA
ARSESIV A AUL FLON CFRTCE O
YI PMLANGT IOL SADED AND AUTBOI
HA8119 T'T'E NL OINHADAN T
TWO
D HA B ONNEF TEE THLA
N
.ES
IE HAVOM SEE MORUB SANSTCEF O
S,TIESON BUT 'REHE'SNE O
ATTLILE TSIMUNG
BIIDT.
IAN WT TRE AODDSSIG RHT ASH OENC
OTWRE IN H LINOT Y IESNROU
TOKBOTHA YOU Q
TEUO.
AYHE SST THAE HOU CLDIL K AL
CKRAITITBB W AHOW BIEFE KNI
FROM ANCIS DTAFE O0 4.AR YDS
,YEAHND A SO C TARLELYS HISTYOR
NISOTRU TEND ARE THE ORE AERTH
IN WCEANSNHEE HAS WOT NHE T
WO
D'R'OSS M RTELBLIAEAR NTORAR
IN
Y MHEWN O W IN R WASHIEAESRC
Y
K BOON O THE BTLESND AHE T
RO
INLLGS.TO SNE
IOMLDOU SIMETESNTNC EOU
ERTH
IKGSIN LS. TEHI
RE
WERU TE A STHS EYNDRE.AT WH
TRRCOEC HS  AAANTOISRI WO TE B
KNAS PNGSING ALONG THI TSTHA YOW
TRSTJU SRENAI C.LIDUTY
ANDO S I W HDEONROUOW YLT DEA
WI TSHIS I S AOLCHAR
TIPASERAE SNGOM TF OORHE LE AND
YTETH MH AUNRODUN ARODNN JOHY
CA
ROMM FRO THEIS HLRITOCA
FA
S.YE
.AH
LLWE,OUNO K IW,'T'CUIF DFILT
AS
S A YW KOUNORO FMNGOR WKIN
BETHE ANLEATS ESSTD ON'HE TR'S
ANOUNO ERMMOS ATUNYTF O M
Y
THATUR SUNRODSNY AF OHE TSE
PUR PEPOTIR LAARDS STANND A A
LOF O ITS ICREL SF-TEEADR O
'S MAURFANUCTEDY BHE TAB L
ER
Y BOT BH,OU YNO K AW,NDHA TT
EISEPODOU KWT THAE LIN
T
HEOUE H CLDIL KLAC A JTABKRBITHA
4FROMS YA0 RDITAYAW WAH  K
,
TRIGHS I IN IHE T'T' AT' ' ISN
LTHEOTERIN N OESF THEAL BDSLA
THERU TEES WTLB AGH, UMRI
TWH
H ICISNE OF O ASER SIEF O
COLBTEP AATS UMTHD.E  HDI
ALLIG R,HTGUR DINHE TARLY AND
S D-MI60ERWHE HEAS W, YOUW, KNO
INLYSIEANGINLU PNGGO INT
DE
CTADDIN.IO D DRPEGRU
DAN T THESNGHI IHA TTN IE SOMF O
OSTHEUM ALB
''LE CARND A HISAG MAN EERNVE
STATTE TEDTHO IS THETHA TOU Y
THERU DGTIDD AICPE HONEL, HDIM
T'TBU 'S CHAARLE TT HE BAMECE
KI OF ODESBSSEH WITINER CTA
ESTHEMIG R IHTNIS HG DRUDU ALT
ST AENDRUNT IERPTHI TSEA R
LQU
K.IC
RESU.
AIHE S W IDTLDOUE B AER VY
JCKLUYBIKRACABTT THAOU WLDN
FRIPESHM DGDD AOSTSIC TS
F
AOW BIE.NI KFE
'I' NT JUSIG RHT RHTIG,
H
I YOUNO KW, IHI TNKVE EGTHRYIN
TABOUEO T MHA TT INO KW TT'H'S A
RYUL POPLBAR AUMIT WH SEOM
ANSHCA F T BS,UT MOE, I'T'NE O
HE TKE WEA OSTFHE TPTON CCE
MSALBUIK LE IT H I'T'DAL CLE
SLLBAADF OHE TRU TET WES ITAS H
SSONGTN O IHA TRET A NOTVEN
SE
T ITNT. WHEES
THR''ET S LEIKN I J NEWSEERY
KTHISD INOFF SEL MGYHOYTLO'
NGTAKILA PCE INHE TIN LES NEROT
N
T' TDHASOU Y KW,NO IUS JT
THENT GHWHD  R IEA.IT
I TN'OU Y'DAV HEO TE BYEA RLL
TODGO A TGOWHRIN A BIEOWNI KFE
RE
LYAL PEDCTRAICO T HIT A
JA
ITRACKBB AN ESLRMNOOUY
UK
IANDTITINSNCMA AVENI ALND
KN
TINOWGETHA HAS WN I SHUC
AE
IBRRLEAY W INMS TERISF O H
DRUGIC ADD
ONTI.
ITUS JTMS SEEETOM CPLYEL
LODIRICU.US
GHRIT?
YOU TAV HEE O BAS HISRIAN
O
UE HAVO TIN KD B OF HEESONT
ABS
HATOU T KIN OFNG THIUC MH
I I WH ISITRUAS W T K YE,OUW.NO
UM IN097RDIC RHA NIX INVEDIT
CHNJONYOHAS T THEHI WTE HSEOU
HEDAN T MET ANDYOH JNNAS CH
PE
DORRFMEND A IEEAN C S WHY
ALRSPEONT WLYANO TEP ACCT A
WHSE HEOUATNV IITUTN,IO B
I
ALCAN  SSOEEHY W SEOOMNEIK LE
JOH CNYAS WIG MHTTAN TO
DEATE INTHCUAR PTIRLA ONE GOE
EN ATOTT B ADNDUTT IAS W AN
STTEINREORG INST
DE W IONDREF I YLD WOUOU
AIEXPL S TNHEF RYTO OATWH
EDPPHAEN
,SURE IEA MNTAT I SEDRTAU BECSE
CAEN WTN OEV TELIOISN AHE T
BE OINNNGHEF TDEC SONEA SNSO
ORHEIR FSTEG RARULSO SEAN
BE
TUSCAEST FHEIRSO SEAFN O
TE SSIVIONWHOAD H B
N EEA
ERSUMMCEEP RLAEANTME SOUN,SO Y
KN
ANDN IUA JAN
ORYF0 197 A HT
E
GIBE OINNNGF THE S HSOEANSAID
AT O ONEFHE TSEOL MONUEOGSHA TT
E
GFT OENTEAV A EHE TND OTHF E
H
T TOWHAOU YW, KN' WE'RE
THKINGBO AUT PCEEAN I T
AONASND I ANDY M FILAMYND STAE
BESI PNDREIXNTDE N AONNDIS H
FOESQUT E.PER AC
NOWHI TS ISEA RNTYLL IESTI
RFO AOT L OFEA RNSSO NOT LSTEA
OFHICHS IT THAHE TRE HADN BEE
MAROEIV P ISTTES TNHE CPLOUE
OF
SON MTHEEF BORHA TTPI EDESO
REAID TIGHE B MORSON ORI
PR
TESOTTSTHAOO T PKCELA IN
SHINONGTN IWE BETCH WENHI
PR NENIDTONIX HAD GEONN O
TONTIALIOEVELISN AND GENIVNA
FTHE SOUAMS MENILTYORAJIT
SP W ICHNCH HKINDF O
DEDDESTRO PTEIGSER R FHTOR
BEG AIL STENUT B VALOC
WRIJOTYE WHOERIAUM HILNGTI
ITE THUNTE SEDTA
SO C YOULDOUEA RCAD SHOM CGIN
OUT,OU Y KNWNO I AN EPIDE TTHA
WAS SELURYAP TOR BEDEFE JUAANRY
DANOR STCIF  ODENGHAT H'E'
YO
W KUNON O S THEEIDF O NIX
DAN WREHEHE WREHI T NSLIOATNA
IBADETEIN TSAKGCE PLA A HE
DHARE PYOUVISLE GONO TIE VAMTN
AN
FO PDEROREDRM FVI SERMECEN
ABAT  EEA YR ALIARERNDVE EATN
IMATTH TE, YOU KW,NOE HAD HE H
OLDHA T TDHECEER SVINMEN
NDATTEHACEAN T HT'AS WN'T
MOVEIGNTME RLI CHTALM TNGHE
AL
R SWEARDWOO SON NIXF OOU C
ERS
'WAS'T A NURATALNN JOHH CYASAN F
NNIXOD KINF O LEDIK BYADROWA
UNOWSH T,ES BUTEB SOMYOD INIS H
H
EIT HTASEOU SOR IFFNFDME HIM
TO
AHI TSIT INDNV HEDIM TO THE
WH
USE ITHOE TFO POERAP IRMN LRI
7019.
DANAS CTOH OK TIT INV
IO,
KNYOU T',OW 'SHE TD KINF O
FA
PIUSMO EDEN I THERYIS HTO
F
HNJONYH' CA'SAR CREE AND IN H
O
LTILICAEMNG EAGECTEN BSEAU
TH
ASEER W TSHIHO WLET DUSP U
WH
EEROM SNEEON IHE TON NIX
E
EHOUS ATA SFFIMEDSK HO T PYLA A
COFLE OON SE LGSIKER MLE
HAARD' 'SROEKI FM MEKOUSGE A
ISEA RYLLUL AWF KDF O R
T
SONG BY GUYRA DKEAL CDLE WFARE
CAACLLREHA TT YOLYAL, ,KNU OW
A
OPS RKPEWE OLEN ARLFE AOU CEPL
ETTYEANGS SON ASAR FS A
ASNYHN C WHASCE CONEDRNN IND A
WH'LDOUN'LAT P HYIM H ANDED KIN
OF HDIDT I G
TLENY.
KYOUW,NOE HEDEF RUSLAO T P
YEM B S SIR TINAYGRESEHE A'N'TH
GS SMYON
G'M AYA NNPL SET YW, KOUNO
T
THEN HE GSOEND A HEYS PLA HIS
DT SEANTS THIT' 'LL RSEA
YIN
INRETESTAU BGEC Y ISEF
ENSTO  T WETHLEHO C,CEONRT HEI
T
TSAR OFFAY SOGIN THI TS
ENDICE OF A00UTBO 3EEO PPL OF
TSGUESHO W YW, KNOYEA RLL
ETTICKHITOS  TFO PSERANRMCE IN
TH HHI WTESEOUT  THAEYTH JT
TWANTNG BORI A LTLITEFIT B O
TH OOU SL TFHE STHOU TO THE
EWHITOU HSEHA TTVE ENGNI BUT
ABOU 20ESIN MUTO INTHOHE T S
E
IN KD OF GSOEFFCR STIP A
NT
TSARKI TAL ANGUTBOOU KW,NO
PUNYOG APLEOENDIOUE QSTNGNIHE T
OSDWIOMHE TIRLD ESERND AE H
UCTRINODS TESHIEW NON SGAL CDLE
H
T IATSTHRUHI WCHLLS I ABO A
R
ESTE ANDT' 'S ALLBO A
UTH
TN VEIE. WAMAR
I'SY VER CARLERO FMHE TSYR LIC
WHHEE  TKSAL,BO AUTOU YNO KW
KI
IDSNYUN SDAINEA TCHDA SGUN
Y
HOOLEXND A NTEA YRIG M BHTE
URSHI TN DAYELIS H DIF LENOW
D
WEW KNO DRO FMANAT RRHO WAS
THE AS ABS CEW NSEP R
TEOR
TTHATREHE PDESINTME SEE A
LI
URLETT S TISPREDTHAER H'E'
THUY GHO WUS JTD SAIONAI SD
VITES LEHOONSI S HTHW AT
ORPPTOU Y KWNOY MLA PNS FORESU
PIG
EAC ANDOW N H'E'E HER S
10T FEE AYWAM FRO MEGI SINNG
EWISTH N SGON AUT YNGOUPL PEO
E
TIQUESINONGHE TIRER ELD ASND
TH SAS CHSAY TO HIMR. M
ENESPRID
YOP HEW KOUNOT THA C YOUAN
GBRIN TS BOYE HOM FTEASR OR
SEVENNEOORHA TN YOUNK THI
U
RICAN HATGH TT WN'A'TT PARF O
E SCPT C.ARLELY
SOT IAK MOR FN ANT INGESERTI
EPNEOD IAS CHS IAG ENGENEMT
WIIEHE T VARAMTN WINER CTA.LY
, WELLOWU YOKNGHHR TOU A LF O
THK BOOOU Y DEDCRESIBS THI
NAMIYOUIBES DCRE H,IM YOU
KNAK M SGINNTTETAME OSR
HOIEGIN VSOIWPNT INHE 6
R
70SHA TTOU CLD BCR DEESEDIB A
LI OLRAN ERVE L,TIEFSTUT B H
HSOAD TS,HI YOU K RW,NO
Y
NGSTROL PP AEATOON CRVATE
ENLISTD S ERAN AERTHEOT ARE LF O
TH WE OSASDL ELAN' DON 'THEEAK T
QUTIESON THE WNGROAY W
.I
THI I AEEGRYOIT WH U
ISALANYS Y B,UT KOUWNOEO SOMNE
TMIGHAY SHA TT LEIKRY EVE
RECOING  JTIARSTNNOHYH CAS
DCAREBO A HUTUL PISOPAR S,CEUCSS
ANE WW KNOHA TTAU BECARSE ELY
HINIS C
EEARR.
HEOW ALLED HISOR RECDAB LEL TO
EGUID SOMOM SEEC DIOISNSND A
E
ARAPPEED LKIOONG ROUICIDUL AND
SOMEHO PHSGRTOAPOR FOM CLRCMEIA
U
.OSRPES
INDOU ISI AMUT TNGHAOU Y
NENTMEIO IDTN I THEOH JYH CAS
SH
CERO PDU HRSADEDEC DIDHA TT
PAHEF O TMU FIROR WOUE B
TONEAV ACTTT ARAOMEIV W OANN
TH SWHO NVE ERYHTIGO S
HA T
MOPL PREEOD WOE UL.TEATND
AIE VERRAW TH
.SOOW H DOOU YNO N
ASNYHN C K YH,OUULW NOWOD YOUO
OWKNAC BKND ATH FORENET BWE
VI
SEWHA TTUL SHO BESI CON
D
ERCONS OTIVAVERALIB LER THAHET
WA''RIRE PVA ATICANGNDUS JT
LYSIMPGRY TIN TOIN FWAYSO
ALAPPEO TS A MYANPL PEO AE YSOU
O
ECDUL BSE HETE WAN TDHE TO
U
REHIY S  RRDCOS,
HTIG?
'IT'S A FAI QNSTUEIO B AAUECSES
UYOYOAY S,  YKNU OWOUOU YIG MHT
THKHA TT ABO AUT ANYISRTT
TRIGH TAN WTSOEE KP WTSANO T
MAINTAHE T LGESTNCUD AIE
EPO
AIBSSLETS WNDANO T YOU KWNO
WILONGLI TBE MAYAK SPE OUTF O
BOID SES TF OOUIRHE M.TH
SOS NOT TOIT EFER HEOF
NDAN
ORODYBY NOOU Y K
YBE CES LSLYICYNAL JTUSAN WTS
NG BTORIBOVE ERYDY TETHE
UYOLD COUAK MET  THAYOSECA,
UKN
.OW
TBU IEA ROKY LLLOED FT. TORHA
UYO KW,NO IYEA RLL LOODKEO T
FIOM SEDE EVIENC TT
ERMESOWHHE EEITRE HHI OR S
R NAMAGEOUREWE Y
NO KW?
RRWODIEBO AUTEN ALIINATGOM SE
OPARTFIR THENCUD AIEE BYIM H
TAGINBO AUT OR SGAKPEIN UP
N
ISONE  AE SUOR.THNOER
ANS AAR FS A IANEL TL T
HEEV
DENIDC'SNOE'XIT E.ST
YOUW, KNO T INKHI CERINLY BY
TTHEEIM HEHEAD H TISEL TEVNIO
EOWSH HAS WN I AOS PIOITNO TE B
U
OR MEEA FESRLS TBO AUTTHA
AN,AYSEEC BAUE H AEADY
D
THISOUNO ERMUDS ANCIEE, YOU
KN
, HEAS WSTAN FTAALICLY
SUSFESUL Y ANDW  KOUNO
U
WAS IF DE HHIID TNKT  THAYBMAE
HE GASNGOI AO TEENLIAT SOME
OPARTFDT  IANE LOST. I
YOUNOW,T 'AS WN'NNT GOAT COS
HIM,OU YNOW NANC
LLIAY
SSNECEORILARY  IN ANYHAAY W TT
WOEC ADFFTWNIS H O SSEEN OF
YO
KNOLFIM HSEIS HESEL SF-EMTE
SHIND STAGIN A ASRTN AT,ISUT B
HIETH T ISE H D WASNGOI TSEHE
.INTHGS
YONOWT THANE O MHTIGAR REGD
AS UOPUL EVEOR BNEFET. THA
YONO KW,E H HRSCOE VESOHA TT
U
ERST.
BY PAFERET LGEAR ON T OHENHE T
BI
EAERTT TLBRS A,UM WCHHIS I
BACALLYBO AUTHE TSA MASE CROF
CUST'H S 7TY,VACALR?IG RHT
AAT THEEIM WKNYON U  TOWHE
'W' T ARETGH HHEEITF OOLHE T C
D
R A TTHERT STA OF THEIE VAMTN
WAHE TSC ENATALIOHEF O T
NAVIET WAR
CITASLDOU E MY ILBE.REISAD
AS AIN KDF O AMILIRISM
KIONF O S AGND H'ID DN'T
K
ANHIYTNG I OF
PSFOERRM IT ON THE TIOEVELIS
H
H  WOWITFFBUYNT SAI,AR MIEOU Y
SOWKN A A STORF OINAU LGHG
THEH UGTH SBORYTO A
YUTU
,KNOWT WHA HPEAPNSO TRG GEO
E
TRARMSUSGON CRTECH WHIS ITT PRE
Y
.UGLY
SO J ITUSON D'' I TNKHIER OTH
HOPPELEEAV KIN OFSS AEDUM
CHRHE S IAROLSNAPIO BGRRSHEOT
INVEHA K ODF A TUMSSEDT TT
BYAB D IINBLGK FNOLIC MUS DNGY B
HE WAS TINRYG TO EANXPD HIS
AUNTCEEN IOE, VOT BNN JUTOHY
SHCAN' DI'TEE NDO TXP E HDAN
IENDICEOLONT FOUK, YW, KNOE HIU
ADALREY HADN A ESRMNOOU
OWFOLLGINVE ENIT WUTHOER VYY MAN
HI SGSONN I THE96 1.0S
AS W ABIOL CUMRDREA CO
SR
ANDE  H AS WAIND.E  HHA
YO HAD AINER CTAMO ATUNF O
FR
DOMECAU OSEFHA TTO TO D
EATWH HD.AN WTE
YO TNO KW,EV THEEL SIOISN
A
LITTLEIT BIF DREFENTSEEC BAU HE
I
'D'E HTAVETOM CPLEIVRE CAT
E
CORONTLTHVE OR ELE TNISEVIO
SH
IT WASAR CLEHA T HTEAD HUE GSST
ON HE WLDOUAV HE RNOHEATR T
,D HAONOU YNO KW AOT LF O
YWHOLLYPDOO TEST THA TT THEHA
THERODPRUCIS ISNSNDTE OEUT B W
KNHA TTT MOS OTHF EUS MALIC
,ESGUTSOU YW  KNOISREWE HDE IA
AR
ADFOT L O ME HAD TO PHUS
TOVEREC OHEBJ OONTISFOM SEF O
THERODPRUCSOS CE BRU
STRISPNGOMN EEWH' ' AM VYERIG B
FNFA OEDAN MAGE HAV AER VYON L
A
HEERRE WRET I WASUI QTE
OB
WOUVISREHE HPA SISYM
IETS
PWEREALITOLIC T ILYN T WHEAYTHA
HEOU WLD RATELEO TPL PEO WEHO
DWERENOWRO TUTND AR O
OP BSEESD, HUTEAG MAN G TEDOO
A
Y VER TON LGEIMIT WUTHO ION'T
THK IV'' ERVE CZITIRICI ANG
ICPUREBLSO PANERNA BNY IL UMENT
NK TIHIHE BRAHUS END A ALLHE T
HELYIN FAL HADNO EH.UGG IHI TNK
AH, JUT B CNNOHYHASER NEV
T
NO, I D'O' ITN, MEA ' IUTT'S
PO TLEIBUT HAYOW, KNO'HE TRE
'S
MOA FA.US
ORSTYAS HEENEC RNTOUEDN I
LELTMUIPSLA PCEF O
STRISPNGN'E'S, YOUW KNO REAELSE
1 4 SHO RHTIG THEON SG
T
GBEINHOTOW DNY  BLIPOCEND A
YTHATNOOU KW REPTERS
RTREPONGIN OOI GNGO T SEEIM HT A
PL AAYTIANTDI STAOU,UM YNO K
,
NOTON LG AERFTHA TTN CEAIN
SPNSTNGEE YAN FS,W  KOUNOENWH
RT SHETAED TOLA PT TYHAON SG
RNINGHE TIRAC BK ON H AIMND
THS AN SOO ASE HRO BKENT IO
SO SIT HGON TRNY HETUED A
D
WEAND ER CREHEAIG INAGIANN D
THKHAAN FS  C TVEHEY.ACAPIT
TOO DHA TTET SOMESIM,NOOU Y KW,
FENEV I KOU YW,NOHEYAYE BN I
VELOIT WHN ART ATISOR F YRS
ANRIENTH WON ATE S
ATTHHE TY D'O'TI PTARYLACURL
CAHEOR F TYIG MHTE BIL WNGLI
TOKOOHE TTH O WAY BECSEAU O
N
LABAENCHE TE LYOVTHVE ERYGIN
YOSEEL, NOU KW,ND A IHI TNK
TH
'SBLOS PSIE TYRUIT WHH CAS
TO
YONO KW, IBLRO PBAW SYHOH WIT
OUR MFRUAUTL ERNDIE JERYEM V
AN
D M SISADONEQU GDEARNRE WHE
EBHE DUTT THAG. SON
ALLHT RIG
AYOK.?
.YEAH
UMLD W IOUIL I WINL FHISP U IN
INA MNDEUT AHEN LETOM SE
R
HAS TO DOIT WH I WAS IAS WLA O
ST
CK B ARB BLUN O THE BKOO
Y
HISTIANET BHYAI BLEND AHE S
SAHA TTIS HASRYTO HTT WRI
E ARNRA A AMUS CHTABS OU ANDENO
O
W KUNO JOHASYNN CCO OHF SEUR
THVELIS
UGROH.
AYEA RLLCUIF DFI ALTND
LTTUMUIMUSUO TEUR DGINHE T
METVINA BRA E,UT NOW T IYNKHI B
MMANYSSUEARE IHI T WNKE MAY BE
EVEN MLAE ORPOZERID AND DIDIVED
H
ANPL PEO WEEER TNHE AND I
WOER HS TOWHITEFF AECR YDOU
AP
TOAPRCH TOHETI WRI.NG
UM AISST TEHA' D ION 'TNHINK
OU BTHT ISKOOOR FON A LG
,
BUTUSOU Y MAVT HE DOSEON MT OF
ERI WURNGTI DE G INTH
UMTP
ERA.
DANO S IDE WON HROWHA TT MHTIG
VE SPEHADR  YAP AOAPRCH
D
THENOU YAN CNTOM CME TNT IOT.HA
ATWHRE AHE T LSOESNS TTHABE MAY
INU YOTH WKE CLDOU OR SULD
M FAWROYOH JNNAS CH ASO PERNDR
WHID D TRY TO TNDNSRACE
PO LCATIL IELABS PSON ME
Y
AMFUNDWATAENL .YS
,WEL'OU Y'REIG RHTT THA D IID I
DDIHI TNKUT ABOT. I
OUOBVIYSLT I WASSIMP IOSTE BLNO
TOND I'ID DN'AVT HO SH MUCO T
DOIT WHOU Y KARW,NO PRCUTILA
POCALIGUR M SESOSHUC AT I
ITDDI W W THHET  TAYHAWEAL TK
AB
OLTOU PICITS IN THE UNIDTE
ATSTES ANDHE TMS TER OFAT DEBE
AN
CU DDISIOSSNT  THAWESE U
OUT,GH YNO KW, ONE THINGT THA
DRES ME CZYRA ISSLW AAY
SPNG INHE TSEIN KDF OIN BYAR
ORMTESF SE, YOUNO KW,IK LEN O
ONECELTI.IG NHT
HIEREVYT'N' A RSEDNDLU BEND A
'ATTH'ST. I
ANOU YNO KW,EO SOM'N'S EHER
I
ORABELRSE CONEATRVIV OR
'EYTH'RE AOC DEMRTRA OLIEP RUBNA
D ANWENO K YTHW ATW, KOUNO LSOT
OF PEOEPLON D''QUIT F SELARY
IN
ATONY OF TATSEHO CS,OREGIE
EV I TYHEHT MIGEL SLLAF-BE
TH
ESSEEMLV WHA TTA' IT'LLS A
DEE.
NDPESN O KD OISTHF E
'IT' FS UPOR DIOCUISSSNND A
T
OFT  THARSSCDIOUES IHA T YT
OWKNN I RENECTRS YE' I,T'SOT N
UN
TMMCOON CHEO ARICOMC,UB PLI
YONO KWIT POL CALICATMEOMNTSOR
YSAHA 'WET 'REIV LGINN ID KINF O
EDPRUNEC PTEENDEDAROLIZIM TESO T
IASTHIORT TNHA JTUSSRI DVEOU Y
NUHE WNPL PEOE SAY
UNTEEDECENAU BDECOS ASELM
RE OLERDSSF WTH' WE'RENGAL TKILA
TABOUEND A WAN C SET UIDPSE WE
NCA SAYY EA NRLECUNEDANTEEND
C
Y.AR
I MN,EA I D'O'NK TTHI S
A HADIV CIL W,AROU Y KW,NOWE
ANE W RERE W REREFO T THE 6
AS AS ALS AO,OU YW, KNO MHAICELS
A
NDNZE AOR MSES RIISAN'S BKOO
IS,OU YNO KW,RI AMECAID DIVED
E CIL WARRS YEAHT RIG
GLKTAIN TBO AUT 6HE0S ATHS E
CI. WLAR
NK TIHIEEO PPLHO W LEDIVN I
E THESS RIPEODERATTH W
EPO
D.RILAZE
OFHTHO TUGF O TMSELSIN LIV
N
CENP URELYNTDEEDIZOL PAR
EDTI
S.ME
SO I'T'T IAS WSIMP IOSEBL TO
WR
HEEIT TOO BKUTIT WHOLS AO
KITHINUT ANGBOHA TIGT RHTHE T
TH
TKIINNGNTHA I TNSHI IS THI
PEODRIF OHE TTN VIEAMAR W WCHHI
DHA CARLELYID DIVEDHE T NIOATN
OFRB UANINPR UISGS OFPU CAM
S
SIUPRISNG RFHTIG OIS DIVNIO
ER,OU Y KW,NO THEER GENIOATN
GAHT RIGVE OR ASRI CSE OF
FA
MP ERXAIG,LE RT THTHAHI TS I
H
T WEAYHITHA TS IS T WAY
ATTHUB PIGCLI FALESUR TDKE
T
ETHDNI UTESTA STE IN 1D9 96AN
SONK T IHINOOU Y K
SHCAY BITNH IABGINHI TS PSITOLIC
OFAT EMP THYTHAST EXISI OEDUTDE
IT WN,HIOU YNO KWHE TSE
RITECAGOT TESHAIN KDF O
DDDRALEHESEORAT CEGSIET THA
WEALSULY USELKO  TTA
BO T
TIPOLI.CS
ISLSE UFUOR F OIM TESIG R?HT
'I'FU USSE R TLOINDSHA TTE W
CANAL TK AUTIT POLSIC AND
THOSERE TMSEBF O DEATND AHA TT
CANEM DDANR,ET BTEOU YNO KW
UR OLI PUBCOM CORNTMEAT TSOE B
REMO N ANCUAEDE MNDOR S ITLUBE
N
E WAYHA TTY THEIS DSSCU
ANERAMICICOL PITTHANS D AT I'T'
OK K Y,OUWNOOR F ALLF OS UOR F
CROUNLDHIREF IHE TY D'T FLEE
KELIHE TYIT F A PLATIARCUEL LRAB
OR FIT IONT ACUAR PTIRLA
TIPOLIOXLCA B KYO, UNDW,NO AN I
THAY W, IHI TT' TNKHAW'S
ATE
LE BTHAI
OTSPDTE K YOUWNO ISHA T THI
S
DIED 18EA YRS AUT,GO BN IHE TW
YWA TTHAE HUG THOHTBO AUTIS H
NSTICIZEE PHI HCT AEDN I A W
H
ATS I AOD M FORUR O
WNTI
S.ME
TEIFRRIC I,HI TNKHA T'T'LL REA
A PLLUTT' TNDHA 'S
HI TK
'THAT 'SNG THEHIHA TT I LEIK
BOSTMO ANN JUTOHH CYASHEND A T
TH ITHG AT IEARNOSHE T MT
REILWHE INGHE SOO BK,IO
IAPRAPECT. TTEHA
SIEE TOEYON D ISEANRE YOU
AROU YON GNA MEERODAT THE
ES
QU
ONTIS?
T?RIGH
WEAN I, WOT TDEM RINOL FKS
TH N
ATY THE CANUT P QNSSTUEIO
QTHE BOX
BTBUOREFEE WET GO TT THA
AEMICH IL, WAS JTON GNASK A I
O
VITELEONSIGR PROAM T TOOPE SAK
OUT.
WWHY D NHYOTORITO  M
E.
BLY,ANATTL LE PEAP
THS E
HESMOTTH BRSROSEREA Y
WE,LL I TNKHI ONE RSOEAN I
S
'THMOE'SRO BERTHS,OU Y KW,NO
HEEYTH TD KYIN OFAI PD FOR ITY B
TCIFANG CHEBS SSOENRS T ALLHE
NDMETI A THI TT'H'S TT'S
PE
ONAPRHS ONREE ASS IHA TTOU Y
OWKNT THAHA TT PDCEREDEHE CH
ASHOW W HNDERE AASWA OF I
T.BU
A ITOLSNK THISNT  IWA''
RELYWA IT 'S'ISINT  H
TET.AMEREN
BTOE SOLA B YNTTA,W KOUNO
NA
HEIN TAY WHAT M W IASINTIENON
A
WHIERLR EER HES IIN KD OF
THUTNGKI O AOU LDUTBOOM SOFE
IESTHE YUESSS,W KOUNOHEN I T
TWAYTHAE HOU WLDRESE IT RFO
E.AMEXPL
AICOL PITAL QNSTUEIO ON HISE RID
THRA TINNTEG SMERE WHE HE
TULWODEAKRSIE VWENHI TSRI TP
OMTO S PECELA A IN'RIMEC'ST PAS
OREOMTHER ILA PCE ANNRIMECA
LI H ANDOUE WLDET GRY T TO GET
EREWS TOD KIN PF OUT
ESSEEMLVHEN I T SESHO OFTH O
E
HALEOP T HTEEE SDME MHUCE MOR
COETAORBL NIT WH AOWT TESIM
E
DCOULE B PREY D AECIRTTUTBO I
IN THEE CASF OAT N AEIVNSRIMECA
O
MP ERXAND,LE A IN THEASE OF
PRERONS HE DIDR OVE TE IMBY
YETH BIMHE T TE WEOET G THE T
ENF OIS HAS LT S HSOEAN'
ORCHMU ME DECIRTUT ABO THE WAY
AT HE TKSAL TOIS HIEWE
RS
TABOU IHO TSEUESSS, H BUTE WAS
NER Y KOUW,NOE HER NEVES COM
AC
SSRO ASS A TINOWG AN
LOIDEO LCAGILEIN OR A PNTIARSA
.LINE
IT 'SAYLWS LEIK' I 'MTUS
ZECITINK TNHIGINUT ABOHE TSE
THGSIK LE YOU A ARENDHI TS I
WHNK T IHIKNYO, U OWNE OF O
OUIE VHORSWE WS I AINSKG
TRRFEED TOH'AS CH'S COVF O
THEOW CYBOK JACLE C NNTMES
Y
ONHE TEF LTN  I65 AS, SNDAYOU Y
KN A TON SGTHAAR PIEODS THE
AIAVLSFIAUS MIC WNS
TIG
PINTOS.ITOLIC
WHOUO D YEE FL ARE SEOM OFHE T
INMATOIL MESSNE TTHA LER
RA
ZECADILI E HDIMNVEO T THE
INPOT O MFINAKGIS H ELIARER
GRDCOINF O TTHA SGONDEE SMERE
MOIKE PARO.DY
LLWE THENT INGESERTIHI TNGUT ABO
ATTHON S IGS HE PSFOERRMHA T
T
SONGN O THEELEVIONHO SW
A
LECOUPIMF O TTES A TEA LST
CI
THAT I CANHI TNKF ONEND A O
E
HEOE DST I WHITHE T THE
EESNNSE HHR TEEISACKI BDAN
ARDAN CKI PLERSS DNSRE UEDP IN
ETHES KDINAGF  OEXDRAGETE H
E
UMCOSTOU,ES Y ANO KW, HNDEIN KD
AUOF L ASGHERFTHE TORPEY RFM
E
TSONGY PFORMHT RIG A TTHE
OPF GIN OEON OF ONE OF TSEHO
EPNDESOD AE HOE G Y OS,H,
OUN
NN, OWTESEESEHI CRELDNR O
SOTHINGIK LEHA T YT,OU KW,NO
' HSOE'TIS S ILLEA MN,T' I 'SYER
STTEINREECGIN BHASEAU TTON SGS A
YOAY SHATAC JKLE CRONTME WTE
ISTIFF EEC YLYVE,OUNO KAKW TES
A
OTSH A ATLL PHE TALITOLICOL FK
SIHESER TOFIN KD HI PL OSAK
F
THEORLDAYING,OU YNO KWEE KP
YO PSITOLICOUO T Y IELRSFS A
LINEN S THEOUG,ON YNO KWHE WN
T
OM C TESONGIN SGIHEOLK
S SONG OOFURAN LD,OU YW, KNO
EPKEHE TOLITS TOELOU YRS
F.
INH  CASSWA AEBL TO K YOUWNO
LSTIL PFOERRM TTON SGES HON
TE
ONVILESISTHO SW OKLIL P AE
LI
LE BF O, FUN YOUNO KW AT
NGCUFOSISER AER PPSHA TTHA
FMSHIELIG RN EHTVE AT HPIES
,O
KUECW,NO BE'SEAU 'S GOT H
IR
UPSEESD N ISE THEOFIN KD
RAAGEXGESTD TECO
ESUM.
WHEIL AT THEAM SEDEIM TE GNDFEIN
YOPL PGEOE, YW KOUNO INHIS
GUNOMOLOGI HEE  ASVEUTBO
RIUNCOTES LNGOTF OOU YNGEN
OPLENHE TSE SUNTTR SIPN I
LO
SNG AESELND A FINNG TTHA
THR'' DIK LE PENECT
PLEO.
KYOUWNOHA TTF IOU Y C HAD
S
LIKET THAN IOWIS H TRON G UNGWI
H
EERO TEE BN AIG FHTVE ERY0
FE
,ETUT BHA TT 'SNOE'APT HN,PE
NOUYO K AWNDT WHA HE SAWUT ON O
THTUN SSE,TR SIPO  S'H'ABLE
E' 'STI SLL AEBLVEO  THA A
H,LAUGNOOU Y K P AWNDEOK A
LILE BITF O, FUN BU' IT'S
CLRRO FM THEAY W TTHA HEE H
SGAENGE TSEHEIT POL IALICUESSS
LROACSSEIK A WIDIE VARFTY O
PO
LTILICASSS IUE AND INAN MY
DI
TERFFENAYS ON T THEIOEVELIS
H
T TOWHAE H SLLTI TAKHO T
SH
ERGSIN VOUSEY RIY, Y KNO
,
'YOU'OTVE GREEE L GIS I WOENOD
INSING YG,OUNO KW,OD G BHESSLE T
US AND ASOU YONEN MTIEDLE MER
HA
OARGGDEKIRO FM MUSGEE, HOW
DITSRT AISE LIKT THA FLEEBO A
T
JONYHNH CAS H ANDGS SISONIS H
EWVIS?
IEA MNOR FHE T MTOST, PAR YOU
,KNOWE HSEEC BAUF OHE T SGNDTAIN
HE HADCUAR PTI ARLLAYERFT THE
LSOMRISOOR RNECD AND YOU
,KNOW HEIN W ASSE TLLHE ARDWAS
A.
HE TET GSHEEL TN ISEVIO
TINKHI YOUNOW, H'E'N I THE
T
MTHAT
ENOMT.
HE WAS IN THEANTHN OF
ANERAMICOU C MRYNTICUSRS STA,
ANEYTHEL HD HIM I VIGYER HH
RDREGAIFVE EN DIHE TY 'D'T
E
TLEXACYHE TAM SEIE VWS AND YOU
OW O THE TIOEVELISHON SWE H
BR
MGHOUTLE HGARD ON AND
RLMEE HGAAGRDAY SGINKI OERO FM
MUEEOG T ANDHE FHT IIDNSE
F
YME,OUNO KW TSEHEON SHAGS T
TWE
N SREEES OIN KDFIK LEE' 'D
IMLLCA HOG DLEHI WSTON SGS
Y
FORCAME ARINSE CONESATRVIVND A
LEPEOPHO WEREKS HAWOU, Y KW,NO
SUAND D ORPPTED CHRIAR
XON.
BUT ONHE TAM SESO EPI HDEE
DETEBUD WTHAS ITH TRU RHTIG AND
N
NDEPI ESOHE WRE HE LETO ARL
RIGUTHG SEIN TON SGHA T'T'
LYREALTI CRILCAF O SROPI AEWGN
THAND N NIE XOSTMIADNI.TIRAON
HEVEN HEGA MUEOLONOGT A
TE
AENDOWUTBO H WHE TYILE ERST AL
TLOGR OF HITEA TSPE HAPNGNI I
ISTH C TNTOURYHETHA TYYE PLAD AN
BU OHFOU CYNT TAI FRSTHA
SU AERNDOU YW, KNOEEO PPL
E
WITHHEIRZE PRI HDFEEIRSND A
THR AIELEPP PNDS AE H KDINF
I
OU,KE YNO KWHEAU LNCS HSELF
AINTO NIATAOSLG TOUP,RI YW, KNO
SO IHI T INKT WAS P HTTREYDAR
FOEEO PPL WH'ID DN'HAT S HREIS
POCATIL VOWSIE TEE F HLIL KEE
I
'D' L ATTIVSTEA GEIM H A
OCEAN T AIRHE T YM,OUNO KONW
THEAM SED KINF O PM TFLAOREDAN H
HANOOU Y K HW,E AAD HID W
NGEF OOL PICITAL VWSIEM FROE
ROTHETSRT AISHA TTOM CEHROU
ONEV THEELIOISN SW.HO
COFRSOUE,E' 'ISS HHO SW SOOU Y
T GETH WLAE STD.OR
YOUW KNONE OF O OWE VURIE WRSAS
S
FNGKI I YOUEE S ANAR AN STTI
WH
OS IIN REMDS YJO OOUF NYHN
SH TAY.
IN MEAEE SOT LS A OF,ISRTTSOU Y
KN, NOTY ONL CNTOURYIC MUS
ARUTS,ST B I WE SCKTIO T
TRCOUNIC MYUSE'TH, E'S'HE TR'S
QU AE FEW WHO I TNKHIE TAK
CEITHRSHIZITENIO SIPERNDLYUS A
EASPKUT O PN OALITOLICUE ISSS
D B OAUECSEOCF SLIA MANIAED C
IDOT,OU YW  KNOORENEV M
ERE
Y.LAGURL
ANDOS ACR K YSOUW,NOGA A IINT
NDKI OFOS ACRSOLHE T PICITAL
TRSPEC K AUMNDD INOFBE IN EETWN
CA TRIGOES,OO YOUNO K
KTHIN MY FEORAVITY MNAER PSO
LFA
RIVOTE WAS BAUECSE IAS AEDSK
NCISTH OEIKS I L IEFODOM SEBY
WERTHEOMAS SODEBYN IOUNT
RY
CMUSI WOD TAYHOOU CLDE HAV A
TE O
ONVILESI LHO SWISE IKTH,
WODUL I PKICND A IAI SDGO MAR
EPRICECAU I TARNKHI MGO
E PRICESDO THEAM SE KDIN OF
LBTSULEEIK EAGNGED CIZITEND KIN
OFN RT A ISIR HEMU
E'S'HES ' MEORF OIK LE A
X
OHOF JSHY NNCAND A WLIILESO NEL
N
D L LETORTARONYN P IBLBAYNHE T
WAYHA TSHT EHE STU CAPS,RE YOU
IKNOW AUESSSUTBO OR EAGNGES
THWIUE ISS TSTHARE AOR IMPNTTA
TO WENOM EAGNGES IUESSSBO A
UT
INFARMAU BGEC SSEHE CROEAM FM A
T TRMHA WAS LTOS IN THE 80S
RMFA CSIRIS AND HERIJ MAR
N.
CAADVOE LCYIK WLIILESO NEL
U
OWKN,ND ANK T IHIND A ANOLS I
YE THWAT THAHE KDIN OF SNDTAS
TEPASERATHRO FM ASE NILLE
ISTAESBL YENHMT, KOUHAW,NO T'T'
MYL SOERNABUEWVI, INI T THK
KYOUW,NO 'REHE'OTS L O OSFERTH
R
WSTTIS AHOREO ALS DNGOI THE
KSAMEDIN OFOR WKND TT'H'
SEN
INURCOAG.SIG GN
YONO KW, I THI TNKST WHEOR
TINTHGTHA H CANPEAPN AS I
AL
DELU T INKS BHEOODUNT IRO
N
IS I TSTHA PPLEOE CANE  HAV
AKN
K -JEEERONACRETI
CTOTIEBELRIES ANDVEN THE
T
ESEARN ATNDL- WELEDFOINRM
ARSSTEC BSEHEYL  FEEKELI
THEIRTF PLASMOR A S ARTASI  ORNG
THSOMENDGIN AT' 'S JIKTUS LE,
UYO KW,NOO GAC BKO  TGNGSIIN OR
EVWHATER IOUIST  YO.
TBU YW KOUNO IIN SNPR FTEGSENOR
EXSE PLHAEE BN VLOYER EENQUT
SOUABTING TTHA THETRT AISAS H
AN INTORMPTAE ROL TOLA PY AN
IMOT
TRTPOANOL RE AS AENIT CIZ
IPLAY THE LFEIF O THEOU CRYNT
DAN IHI TNKASHER UNDTHOOSTD
TINC IVETILYTITINSNC
LYVE.
NONEW OF ONE O OF OURWE VIE
STIMEAS CHOU WLDAK SPE BDEOLRRSA
TH
ANTH OERIS ART B,TSUTN THE
THWILL STIOM S PIMETESLUL THI
SNCPUHEN IE OW H HD RAPHSESHI
ISITCRIC.
YE,AH TT'H'S A RLLEAY
STTEINREESG INQU
ONTI.
I TNK YW KOUNONE OF OHE T
HAGSIN TTEC B CEAMARLE TO MEH
INHENGOI TEA RESORHRC F THE
WBOOKASHA TT H YEOUNO KW,E H
RSENTEHE TSESAT WERTT PREY
IVNTTEATKEY ELLIOR FMP EXA OLEN
THLO BOD SWEATND AEA TRSUM ALB
WH KYOE UW,NO IT C BEO N
ACHANTDE TT HEAK MES THEIR F
T
ETHREGS SONN THAT AUMLB TSHI
KI
NDF OARRONGWIE TALF O BCKLA
O
INRKG MEN INME ACA,IGHT,
TBUE H 'SNOE'EAT RYLL
AL CL
NTATTEONIO TORT I ST OF LEIK
TINAYGHESO PRI CNSCEONRT ANDL
BETFI.HO SWS
HE 'SOTIK LEGAV WIN HIS HD
NGSAYI' 'MERUT O HG DOE IN
.
BUT OR THEEOU CRSF  OSE TH60
YDAN B THEIM TE HEAS H
HIS
VITELEHOONSI SECHEW  BESOM MEOR
O
T,IDNFENOU YW KNO IN SGAKPEIN
OU ASIZ C AITEN ANDAIE H S
DHI
TELMSFT BHE TIM TE HIDE D
THRIT BTE AEA TRSWHUMLB, HIC
NLSWA OY A FEW YFTRSEA AHEER T
BLDAT SWE TND ARSEALB A.UM
WAS DULEON PISNGLI H P.CHUNES
I' DO'THI TN'HA TT'NTS EELIRY
TRSEEC BAUE H DID KF DIN OLLPU
SHIUN P AESCHTL LITE BIT O
IKGSIN LTN VEIENDAM A INK THIH
CYOULDOUCH WAT THEV T SWHO OR
RE
TA AAD SS METENTD D ANANSHWI
NOUYO KW AS AAS CHAN F WHO
S
ONERAY W OERNO ATHUT ABO A
CALIPOTIUE ILSSHEHA TT AD H
ENBE.
MORE BDOLT THA HE HAD SPON
T
MOREGLTR SONY ORPSER PHAES L
S
HTTRIG ALYTIM TCE OESN
AIRN
ESISSU
AND YOU KWNO WHYE H DID OR D
IO
DTOT THA IHI TNKS IOT N
ALNTYSWA E CELIRY BARLE, IUT
K INBY THEE TIM HE GOT TO THEH
E
ONVILESI AHO SW ANDOSCRS THE
ARSF THEEV TELIOISNHO S
W.E
G IWREINRENCASYGL CFIDE
R TINHEOUE,OL Y
NO KW.
IAS WNGDEONRINGOO LKI AT YROU
BO.OV CER
UYOAV HEH CASINRA WPPGSE HIMLF
MEHE T AFLCARIN  AAGNDHE TAY WIN
ROUICOL PITSS I NOW ONE WOULD
ASMEHA TTS IY V AER
VANSCOERIEVETI V
IN MEAOU Y YOU WLDLD WOUOUUT
HI
MN I THETAED R SSKETE STA
IASUS JT CIOURUSBO A TUTHEHE T.
OICHCEHA TTNDOU Y AOURDI ERSTO
R D HAFOE E THTH
VECOR.
HELLWE TEHO CIC'HE TR'S'HE TRES
OT L OFHO PHSGRTOAPF ONN JOHY
CALAND A FIG,GS R?HT
E MHEAD A CPLOUEF OSLB AUMN
E0S 7 RGEAGD OLD FGLALB A
UMN
AND  AHAUMLB T'T'DAL CLE
ICAMER YA,OUW KNO AEA00 2 Y
RSA
N.TELU I
'NGSO 'M GTINGHE TUB S
TLE
G,WRONUT B OOT BHFHO TSEOU Y
SPEAPAR TIT WHHE ARICAG FNLA
ANHE TDAG RGELD O FG.LA
RITLLEAYS I AAGGED OLD FGLA
BEINNGG NDHI AI MININ KD
F O
TIPOIN ANGTT IND AOOKING
AT
THYOU ERVIE EW
BU INK THIOU Y ONO KW,IOUS
AGE THFL
ISS THI SBOYMLT THA LS
DED
MWITH ANIEANGND W CEAND REA IT
N
S LOTF OIF DREFENT WSAY I AND
H
OVE CTH OERF .BOE OK
TOE. M
WH''ESNT IERSNGTI ' HE'S
GLDHOINISP  UTH
LA FG.
'ATTH'INS KDF  ORNTO AND
EDTTTAER
W, KUNOHI TSS NOT ALA FG
' HATE'S AUTBOO T FLY UPHE TTH
APOAGLE HNDE HSEIMLFKS LOO AFL
TTLEORNND AAT TRETED,OU Y
AOWKN, IT'SOU YW, KNONK T IHI
ITS.LEEFCT
IN THE ELYAREN SEVESTIN WHE T
H
PHOGOTRA W TENAK, K YOUWNO
THTA STE OF T UONNI AND
APRHS THE OTA STEFRI AMENCAE
NSTICIZEP.HI
N MIEAYOS MTLE WHTHO TUGT I WAS
RED BLYOL IMA IGEN A
RE T
EIMAGO T GO WHITHE TIT TLEE LIK
I
ZETINH, CASUT BT ILS AO
REINTSEC KDHEF O T WATS AYTH
YONCAEA RDIF D MREFENTSNIEANG
IN CHASN I HISICOL PIT
AD
THE WAYT THAT THA HAS HDPEAPNE
RI
T?GH
'IT' HSDARO TEP SATARET. I
TISOMES A TTHAAN WOMT AHE T
HEAT T ATIUCONOU HSEND A I
TEDEBADR  OVEGGRAEDLD OG. FLA
NOUYO KW, SHEHTHO TUGT THA
S
CLREANCVI EDEEHA TET HAS W A
DI
TH IEDN EL WOO P,RIATOTOU Y
KN
AOWNDSTH OERHI TT TNKHAONG
IS YOUNO KW, C ATIQUF O
ICAMER T OAFRI AHEMET TCAHAE H
WAVILINGN  IATHE TIM TE,OU Y
AOWKN,T WNDHAAD HAP HNED TO
TH
G FELA DINURGHE TER WATTEGA
FARYES,MP EORXALE IYEA RLL
WIREAGE  YTHOUUS JT TOUM JPN. I
'VET JUS' 'TUM SYCK B
IVCAPTYEDAT B PHI TS.TUICRE
I'OOVE LDKET AT I A
OT L.
AND YESOR FOM SE RSON
COVEVAERTI M ASREEORNE PROO T
VIWANG
LA FG.
BUT IHI TST'S 'SN I BCKLA
NDA
E.WHIT
''EDRE DSSN I.LA BCK
'ERTHE'MES SO AINTHGUTBO HIS
GEVISAXPND A ENSSREIOHA TTS I
A
LELITTUTNS ICRLEAB A I'T'
ALRELYOT NAR CL'HA WT'EIS B
NGI
DIFGNIEHIN I TNG TSHI
.I
HINKT'SNE OF TSEHET' 'S
WOUDERS A
NCIEE.
SAY ITES RRCEAHOS RESKHA TT,
PRCT ESXA D ILYNNTFEIFRE
,
BUT I WAS IV''N BEEME MES
ZD
BY TT.HA
AHYE.
CASHE?HA CNG YOUIE VJO OWSF NYHN
ROTH YHOUGUTSER OURE
CHAR.
IEA MNF I YOUBA GO CK T TOHE
U
KNOW TO V THEYERNIEG BINRE WNGHE
I WAS AOU KW,NOD KINF O LEAT
BR
CKIEANGANHAS FIK LEY MY
ME J ORYF CNNOHYHEHAS W INAS W
A I KIDSARIM SIL J TON'S LI
ERMEREMB. HEDIM
INDOG TSEELEVIOISNPE S
,
WHH ICIHO THTUGER WED  KINOF
AREDDSOW TAR, YOU KW,NO MY
PA
ANTRESER ONDLD GIOERENAT
NSN
IDN' DID ''ID DN'TET GOM SE
OF
THEALOR CNBL,UM HORND A I
JU I DN'I'LYRET AL GETIM H,
OWU YOKN I,N' DI'TNO KWNY A
G
TABOUIS H SONDEC ROREA YRSND A
SE TINHO D TS AYITTIK OOUNL THE
S THE WNMERINCADIEC RORSNG
BUALMSE CAMUT OND A I I WTEN
NDCKBA A LIS TNETEDO THEUN S
RDRECO PANS D ASORINUMLBS A
NDA
IKGSIN LE TTHA AND IAM BECE
TYPRETONAS PSISHE ATCA
AN F.
BU IT TOU YNG THEHIHA TT WHA
GO
MTE SRTTAEDAS W THEIE VAMTN
R BAUECSET THA WAS WREHE IAD HWA
DONELL A MEA RYESH AND IAD H
WRHINTE T AS TICRTLEAMTHA CE
VET OUSEARL RAYE
AGS O.
'WASNR'T  TLYALGNKHIINT  THAI
WAR EVEOI GNG W TO ATERI
.
SAND TOHEHI TNGHA TT IEA RYLL
LE
INEARD TNHERS COUEITF  OWRG
TH
OKBO.
WAT JSUS HOWYEE DPLE H
WAS
GEENGAOS ADCRS ALL OF
HE TE
ERDIFFTENSS ISUEDINC ILUNG AND
ES CALCILYILIV RHTIGS RHTIG
INCLINUDNAC RESEEC BAU HE
FMSHIELEV NERLL REAYRO WTE AUT
NIT IR ORO WTEY VEREIT LTLBO A
T
S N  IHIOGTOAUBIS.PHRAIE
AN HDISER OTH BHEGRIOAPN' DRSI'T
HAVEUCH TO SAY IT, FNAC H'E'
OFKIN ND OFTI CRIZECIDOR F
ERGIN V OYENSPUTOK ON BALEHFBE
OF
EAT NIVMERINS AND NOT
MYISANGBOHUC AUT
N-RIAFCAANERAMIC T BS,UTNHES A
ITUR TNS OUT ANDS IINXP ELAED
AS AHO WLE CPTHAER DEDICEDATO T
IOCASHE, RNACE H WASPL DEEY
COTEITD TO UERST TDIANNGHE
INSUISE  T ATONDGIENO GAAS INGT
AENIT CIZ AND SOHA TTAS W
LYOBPRABIGHE T BSTGEUR SISPRE T
E
KNYO, U
OW
EON IT WANO TNESK A OAS L
ITIESONYOF U IFOU YNAD H AQU
OPYUNRTITO TIT SWIOW DN
THJO
NY CH.
ANDSK AIM H AUE QION.
LD WATOUHAOU Y WD WOT ULUYO
M?K ASHI
WELLHE TREO RE A SNYMA
ESTIS.
SEA MN, NJUO ST
TOTO.
WHO TOEA B ATEA DD HNDSEOR A
ST
K WH TE SHEAM TMEHEUT B
W, KUNO' I 'MTEERNTESND IHE TYO
SSICIONHA TTE HE MADBO A
UT
NGMAKI BHA TTODLO SATWE A
S TEARANBUALM IFSPD ECALICLY HE
KEMASALYR LIC DNSISECIO
UHE TATPDESIC LHEYR ASNDOME
OF
HE TGS SSEON WRECHHI AOU Y
OWKN,E' 'E LREIKELEA LDBGS SLYON
ORSAM FOUK FOL OON SGS IRN THE
SE OF ATHNOER MANON D GON
WWEREON AAS SGOU YOU WLDNL OY
HA HRDEA ONN ALOM L
GRDCOIN IND AD KINF OHA CRTRE
THEHAAY W TTTH OERTSRT AIS
U
,KNOW UATPDEDHE TON SG AND
D
RTHEISYR LICASUT B CHEVER
RE
ALLYAL TDKEBO AUTT. I
ER NHEEVE H NEREVAI S
D.YE
.AH
ISTHS IHY W IID DECED TO ADD
TH
ISIN LE ORHA TTE LIN AND IN
AN
MHEOTRE DANONMA HE ATS KETH
SO
ENEV FOR MENIGHRITENGHA TNT' I'S
EVEREE BNOR RECVEDDE EOR BREF
EN
IDLD WOUOV LEUSO T JALKO T
HIUT ABOHA TT,OU YNO KWBO AUT
ASATWH WNIAP HPE H INGNISIF LE
INIS H IIN MDN A ARIMECA TTHE
TI
MEHE TY ME HIMEC DEIDO T
KETAHI TS A PEALRDY STTREYRY
SO M AND EE AKITARN VESCR.IE
'YOU'AVLL HE EDYRYVEBOL WIL H
V
PPAN OTYTUORNIO TO TEA LRN
E
THEK BOO ISIZ CITENAS C MH
L
STEWT.
YFOLEAN WT TONK THA Y.OU
JANTHKNOHIL MCMNCA ALLPEA
BO
ASSOK HHE T HASIE COP OF
CIASNZE CH WHITN AOG AUT
D
PBOOK IYELADDEINN SI
YT WOUANO TET ITRE THESO
LEGENTN.ME
ANTHK YOU ALL VYER
UC MH.
NJI EEDOYIMHI TS Y.NSMEEL
TH
YOK U.
DANOI JN N USTEXIM TE AHE CCK
OULLCA APEA BKSOOVE ESNTOR F
OTNT ERVEHO ASUTNT ERVES
T
AREOM CP.GIN U
TH A YKOU ANDE  HAV
GOD
INEVEN
'REHE'S A LKOO AT BEIKSOO B
NGPU
D ISBLHEEEISTH W
INLNIN LCOND AHE T FHTIGOR F
CACPEE'N'N JS